there's nothing you want to say at all
his wife Emma did not want to talk about
any aspect of the trial when we caught
up with her as she left the courtroom
this week the scene when L chapels
mistress testified with Emma looking on
was captured by renowned courtroom
artist Christine cordell cordell talked
with me outside the court this week
about that moment I sit next to Emma his
wife and she is just like oh my goodness
what an iPhone you can't help a
double-take on this woman she's just
like tied up like a bow and El Chapo you
know I'm quite sure he's had something
done to his face because you know how
when someone's had a little face work
you don't really see the expressions
register when the man smiles it's kind
of more like a grimace and do you see a
motion from his wife you know she's a
funny one I mean I'm quite sure that
she's listening intently and all there
but she plays with her hair and looks at
her fingernails and sometimes she smiles
a little and I've seen her look actually
very serious and there was one day when
she actually she brought her children to
court and they rolled in a shopping cart
with 40 sets for tak 47s
she saw that roll into the courtroom she
grabbed her children and ran out the
door
no chapel's wife has been in court
almost every day saying very little to
reporters she is a former beauty queen
born in the United States reporters say
she's put on a brave face knowing her
husband may spend the rest of his life
in prison dealing with the sordid
details of her husband's mistress
relationship of course I was drawing
Emma the really fun day was a day when
they wore the matching velvet Blazers I
think that was to show solidarity they
both had the same we're a couple yeah
we're the we're the king in the Queen
and you're just in your prison garb babe
you know and Cornell said El Chapo's
mistress broke down in tears after her
testimony the day that she first took
the stand it was emotional because she
said that this whole thing was confusing
to her that she was testifying against
him and you could hear her crying in the
back she when she left the room they had
a mic on her and she was sobbing it was
the whole courtroom we were hearing her
sobbing because she had to testify
against the men she loved her once loved
she said she was very confused by it
because she really thought that they
were a team partners